motive people keep making movies about a
guy who shoots webs out of his wrists
because they're fun and that's not just
true for the audience the people making
them seem to be having a blast to hear
us sometimes when things got a little
silly on set in spider-man homecoming
Tom Hollands Peter Parker has a full and
busy life in addition to super heroics
he's got to juggle homework with a spot
on his school's academic team not to
mention working as an intern at Stark
Industries in one scene he tries to talk
his way out of an upcoming academic
decathlon and his advisor won't take no
for an answer
Peter sputters up a list of his
responsibilities and it turns out that
responsibilities as something of a
trigger word it's the crux of a
spider-man mantra after all when he
flops a line he can't help but break
character give a right turn to the
camera and recite the phrase predecessor
Tobey Maguire made mainstream start and
my internship you know I got a lot of
responsibility with it with great power
comes great responsibility when
spider-man 2 opens Peter Parker is
already in Jordan lots of spider-man
he's in college at this point but still
the same clumsy guy in public
picking up none of the gracefulness of a
superhero side at once seen a Peter
drops all of his books and school
supplies while walking on campus but was
supposed to happen what came as a
surprise that Tobey Maguire was what
happened next as he stays in character
crumbling and picking up his things as
other students walk by one face us extra
slams our backpack into McGuire's head
and catches a strap on his neck
this blue fur is actually a prank
courtesy of director Sam Raimi he's the
guy with the backpack surprising McGuire
and making him laugh while spider-man
isn't as loaded as Batman or powerful of
Superman he just have one big thing in
common with them he's an orphan those
other guys were raised by a butler and
some kindly farmers while spider-man
grew into a goofy and friendly team
thanks to his Aunt May and Uncle Ben in
a rapid-fire barage of bloopers from the
sets of spider-man homecoming Ned played
by Jacob battlin and Peeta tried to talk
to Liz about the current team party
scene and Peter mentions how parents
sometimes that their kids throw those
parties that bit of dialogue sends
Holland off the rails he remembers that
his character doesn't exactly have
biological parents anymore they let you
have parties you know my parents they're
dead
a quiet heartfelt moment with the object
of your affection can make even the most
confident person into a tongue-tied mess
but hey sometimes deep thoughts and
feelings are better left unsaid right
that would make one spider-man too
blooper extremely realistic except Tobey
Maguire isn't supposed to be so
worthless leaf plugs in a cute romantic
scene with Kirsten Dunst who's playing
Mary Jane Watson Hey today's credits he
sells that mistake is simply being
overwhelmed by emotion but then he
realizes he's been silent for way too
long and not the jig is up part of what
makes spider-man such a great character
are the differences between the bold
superhero and his mild mannered
alter-ego spider-man is Peter Parker of
course but they're also total opposites
at least for the casual observer
for example spider-man glides through
the air with the greatest of ease Peter
Parker on the other hand is a gangly and
timid teen who's not quite comfortable
in his own skin in spider-man homecoming
the actor meant to embody both Peter and
spider-man have really nailed Peter
Parker's awkwardness Tom Holland is
almost too deep in character the actor
apparently tripped slipped and stumbled
quite a lot to join the making of the
movie maybe Tobey Maguire feels
uncomfortable doing romantic scenes and
action Harry superhero movies or maybe
he doesn't think the idea of introducing
the comics character Gwen Stacy is
necessary for the already overstuffed
spider-man 3 which already had so many
characters or maybe the actor is just
gone a little stir-crazy from playing
spider-man in three movies over five
years whatever the reason Maguire
constant to get through filming close-up
coverage and what's supposed to be a
simple exchange in which Gwen introduces
herself to the Daily Bugle photographer
what's at the blonde wig
spider-man's web swinging is a
special-effects achieve or some
combination of green-screen CGI and
actors suspended from gravity defying
wires being harnessed up like that to
start exactly a natural or comfortable
state it takes a lot of effort to get
used to let alone do a good job of
acting in that condition on the set of
spider-man homecoming Tom Holland
couldn't seem to get the hang of those
dangling wires he tries to turn is an
ability to navigate the wires into a
little dance in front of his concerned
co-star donald glover a more wire bass
shenanigans while shooting a night scene
for spider-man 3 Tobey Maguire guys
Kirsten Dunst down to the safety of the
ground while notably not wearing a
Spidey suit done stuff so much fun with
the descender she lets out a couple of
hoots
which seemingly causes Maguire to forget
his line he improvises some silliness
instead let's go get on my bike in
Avengers infinity war when Thanos stops
half the universe to death
spider-man falls into the arms of his
mentor Tony Stark before turning to dust
it's heartbreaking
which means Holland probably wanted to
keep things light and bouncy when its
carrots a miraculously returns and
Avengers endgame in fact the actor
literally bounces around the
rubble-strewn set much to the pleasure
of Downey jr. who hugs the Boy Wonder
for just a little too long and even
plants a kiss on his cheek welcome back
wall-crawler
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
superhero movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you